I'm thankful for how you've designed, um,
just gathering with people to operate so that uh, no matter
what we have going on in our own individual lives, uh,
we have one another to lean on, to equip one another, to
shoulder and share our burdens with, to hear
what you're doing in their lives and our lives,
and share a collective experience together as we all look
to glorify you, worship you in our lives.
Speak to us tonight your word.
I pray that you'll open our eyes to see things about you
and about your creation
and how it reflects your glory
as we examine your word tonight.
We love you. We thank you for your son Jesus,
and the salvation we have in Him.
It's in His name we pray. Amen.
Well, I do thank you all for coming tonight.
Uh, my hope is that this study of systematic theology
that we've been going through this semester, uh,
has been both educational on the one side
and stirring in your souls, uh, as we've
considered the riches of God's glory together
through these topics as we've looked at the word
and how God's word illuminates and,
and highlights these aspects of his creation, of who he is,
um, how the world
and life operates together as we've examined that together.
And I want to thank Trevor.
I don't know if he's here this evening. I'll see him.
Um, we thank Trevor for meeting our discussion last week.
Uh, so last week we went through the first part
of the doctrine of man.
We highlighted God's design
and purpose for creating humanity,
humanity being his image bearers in the world.
We're going to continue that topic tonight.
We're gonna zoom in a little further into
what humanity looks like according to God's design,
specifically how he created humanity, us as humans, male
and female, for his glory and for our goods.
That'll be our topic tonight.
Uh, before we get into that, I'll introduce myself.
If you don't know me, my name is Chris Cross
and I've had the privilege, the humble honor of getting
to serve as winter elders over the last year.
Uh, it's my, honestly, it's my joy
to serve the church in this way, um, in more ways than I've
realized, um, before even serving in this role.
It's been, it's been an honor
and I speak on behalf of all the elders
when I say if there's anything that we can do, uh,
to serve you, to care for you, to pray with you
and for you, please let us know.
Um, we meet, um, every other Tuesday, the first
and third Tuesdays, uh, of the month as our other meeting.
Uh, we meet from six o'clock until
whenever we finish at the evening.
Please come join us for those meetings.
If you have any specific things that you would want us
to pray for you on, please let us know.
We'd love to have you come in and pray those times.
So, um, let's let, just let us, let me let remind you
that we are accessible to you in that way.
Alright, so let's get started on our topic tonight.
If you'll bear with me, I want to start
with an exercise here.
Sometimes these feel awkward, it's gonna be fun, trust me.
So go ahead and close your eyes.
Nothing weird about closing your eyes.
You might fall asleep, that's okay.
But as you close your eyes, I want you to picture
that you are suddenly in the middle of a crowded street.
There are sounds of people all around you
walking briskly this way and that way.
All kinds of people are in this crowd.
There's young, there's old, there's women, there's children,
there's groups of internationals all around you.
Everywhere. There's people just every direction you hear
them, there's almost overwhelming
noise everywhere.
There's machines creaking, there's bells ringing,
there's a man shouting in the distance,
there's a toddler crying.
There seems to be this endless refrain of music all around.
You can't really quite tell where it's coming from,
but you haven't opened your eyes yet for all you know.
You really could be in Times Square,
you could be in Tokyo, you could be in Tulsa.
Maybe you're standing in midway at the great state fair
of Oklahoma, But
then you open your eyes.
So go ahead and open your eyes and you see a sea
of these everywhere around.
So where are you? Disney World,
maybe Disneyland depends on your west coaster or not.
Yeah, Disney World unmistakably, you are at some
sort of Disney Park.
And how do you know
Branding Brandy, right?
Well, everywhere. One, everywhere you look,
you see these, right?
I don't know if you've been to a Disney Park recently,
but it wasn't like that when I was a kid.
But now every single person in the park
wears something like this.
Adults, kids, everywhere.
But it's not just the people wearing these ears.
Everywhere you look, you see those sets
of ears everywhere You see it on the pins that the,
that the employees are wearing.
You see on the signs, you see even pictures and the flowers
or how the bushes are arranged, the statues,
the video screens, the ground even has those ears.
Everywhere you look, you even hear that high pitched voice.
So, oh boy, everywhere, all the sound,
it's the best I can do. Pretty
Good.
Even in unexpected places, you find
what are called hidden mickey's.
I didn't know this was a thing, but this is a thing you find
hidden Mickeys everywhere and the hedges
or the decorations and the walls.
And there's a whole subculture about fun
around finding these hidden Mickeys in Disney parks.
This place is saturated.
You could say with Mickey's, one could even say
that Disneyland
and Disney World is filled with the image of Mickey.
And that language sounds con familiar, doesn't it?
How does that language sound familiar to you?
Deal with the image of me.
Anyone?
Christ is the image of God,
Christ the image of God.
Where else do you hear language about
filling a place with the
We were made in the image of God. Made
In the image of God. Yep.
The Holy Spirit filled their room
Filling. Yeah,
filled the room.
We talked a lot about this topic last week, right?
Trevor led us in some discussions
that there are similar phrases all over the book of Genesis.
Things like filling the earth, being created in the image
of God, that imagery we see.
Um, I'm just gonna as a side note,
encourage you if you've uh, not ever spent a lot
of time in the Book of Genesis, please do.
Um, and if you have in the past, do it again.
Um, there is so much in the book of Genesis
that every time you look at it
and study it, God opens up my eyes
to brand new things about him, his creation, us about Jesus.
His redemptive plan for, for humanity
and for creation is just littered
all through the Book of Genesis.
So please spend some time in that book.
But as we read last week, as Trevor pointed us to last week,
we begin to see language like this used in the very
first chapter of Genesis.
So if you had your Bibles, go ahead
and turn with me to Genesis one
and we'll someone, someone read Genesis one versus 26
through 28 when you get there
And God said, let us make man in our image
after our likeness And let them have dominion over the
fish of the sea and over the birds of the heavens
and over the livestock and over all the earth
and over ever creeping theme that creeps on the earth.
So God created man in his own image
and the image of God created him, male and female.
He created this and God bless them.
And God said to them, be fruitful and multiply
and fill the earth and subdue it
and have dominion over the fish and the sea
and over the birds and the of the heavens
and over ever living thing that moves on the earth.
Yeah. So we talked
about this passage last week.
We're gonna, we're gonna focus in a little bit
deeper on this tonight.
So I'm gonna write this verse out here
'cause we're gonna come back to this in just a bit.
But before we do, before we really focus in
on this, I want us
to build a little bit more on the major biblical themes
that we see laid out in 26 through 28.
Because they're gonna set up a lot of
what we talk about tonight.
So God, in this creation account, he states
that he created man as male
and female to ultimately multiply
and fill the earth with his image.
Just the command that he gave man to do right And acting
as his representatives over all created things on earth
to subdue the earth, to rule over the earth.
And this isn't the only place
that we see this instruction given actually it's repeated
multiple times throughout Genesis
and the rest of the Old Testament.
And I want us to take a look at that
so we fully understand what God's doing here.
So if you don't mind buckle up
and follow this pattern with me
because we're gonna go through this together.
I'm gonna start in Genesis five.
So just a couple of chapters later.
Genesis five verses one through three.
And regarding regarding Adam
and his offspring, it says, when God created man,
he made him in the likeness of God, male and female.
He created them and he blessed them
and named them Nan when they were created,
when Adam had lived 130 years, he fathered his son,
pay attention to this in his own likeness after his image
and named Seth.
Continue on a couple chapters later, Genesis,
Genesis nine, Starting in verse one.
Now this is regarding Noah.
So the previous was talking about Adam and his offspring.
Now we're looking at Noah starting verse one says,
in God bless Noah and his sons and said to them, be fruitful
and multiply and fill the earth.
And then again in verse seven,
for God made man in his own image and you be fruitful
and multiply, increase on the earth and multiply it.
Skipping over a couple more chapters, Genesis 11 verse four,
this is in context regarding the peoples when they were
building the city, city
and the tower of battle, the people there said,
come let us build ourselves a city
and a tower with its top in the heavens
and let us make a name for ourselves
lest we be dispersed over the face of the whole earth.
So this is a little bit different,
but I want you to recognize something here.
Do you see the problem?
There is said, let us make a name for ourselves
and with the reason was lest we be dispersed
over the face of the earth.
So what was, what's the problem there?
What was God's command for humanity?
Multiply and fill the earth to multiply and fill the earth.
So here's the people that are basically
disobeying that command of God to fill the earth
and they're saying, let's know,
let's just stay here together and not be dispersed
and make a name for ourselves.
Right? So what does God do?
Confuse the language. He confuses their language.
And then what happens in verse nine?
Yeah, look at verse nine it says,
and from there the Lord dispersed them
over the face of the earth.
So from here, God's blessing the earth
by multiplying his bear image bearers,
even when it's against their will, he still fills the earth
with his image barriers.
But then starting in chapter 12 of Genesis,
the focus switched from switches from this broad view
of humanity to one family.
So Genesis chapter 12, starting in verses one through three,
speaking to a Abraham Lord says, go for your country
and your kindred and your father's house
to the land that I'll show you.
And I'll make you a great nation and I will bless you
and make your name great and see you'll be a blessing.
I'll bless those who bless you
and him who dishonors you I'll curse.
And in you all the families of the earth shall be blessed.
So do you see this continuation, the theme of blessing
through multiplication and filling the earth
but now focused in on, carried it to one man
and his family, Abraham and his family.
And it continues. Genesis chapter 17 verse six, to Abraham,
I'll make you exceedingly fruitful
and I'll make you into nations.
Genesis 17, 15 through 16 to Sarah Abraham's wife.
I'll bless her. And
moreover, I'll give you a son by her multiplication there
and I'll bless her
and she shall become nations extreme multiplication there
kings of peoples shall come from her.
Moving forward a little bit more on Genesis to chapter 22,
verse 15 through 18 regarding Abraham
and now his son Isaac.
God says, because you have done this
and have not withheld your son, your only son Alice,
surely bless you,
and I will surely multiply your offspring
as the stars in heaven
and as the sand that is on the seashore
and your offspring shall possess the gate of zenes
and any of your offspring shall all the nations
of the earth be blessed because you obey my voice.
But if you continue on through Genesis,
this promise doesn't end with Abraham or Isaac.
It's carried on to Isaac, his son.
We see that in Genesis 26 verses one through five
and then to Isaac's son Jacob in Genesis chapter 28
verses 12 and 15.
And again to Jacob in Genesis 35, verse 11.
And God said to him, I am God almighty, be fruitful
and multiply that same command that was given to Adam.
He says, be fruitful and multiply a nation
and accompany of nations shall come from you
and kings shall come from from your own body.
Forget this, the theme doesn't stop in Genesis
looking at Leviticus chapter 26 verse nine,
God declares that if his people Israel follow him
and his commands, he says, I'll turn to you
and I'll make you fruitful and multiply and you
and and will confirm my covenant with you.
And I'll walk among you and will be your God
and you shall be my people.
It sounds a lot like the Garden of Eden, right?
Same imagery being fruitful
and multiplying the nation of Israel.
And God says he himself will be among them.
It well among them, walk among them, God with humanity
and humanity multiplying his image.
But if you've read through the Old Testament, we know
that Israel doesn't follow God rightly, they don't
uh, represent his image well.
And then in Jeremiah chapter 23, verses one through four,
we see God declare through the prophet Jeremiah, woe
to the shepherds who destroyed
and scattered the sheep of my pasture.
You have scattered my flock and have driven them away
and you have not attended them.
Behold, I will tend to you for your evil feeling,
but then listen to what God says he's gonna do.
He says, then I will gather the remnant of my flaw out
of all the countries where I've driven them.
So bring them out from all over back
and then what does he say?
I'll bring them back to their fold
and they shall be fruitful
and multiply the same command over and over and over.
So we follow this pattern through the rest of scripture.
Ultimately we see this redemptive plan for God's people
fulfilled in the coming of the good shepherd in Jesus
and Nazareth, the offspring of Mary,
God's exact image, his exact image bearer come to earth
as a man, but then
resurrected as Jesus was, as the firstborn
of a newly created humanity, a new Adam.
As scripture tells us, don't miss the significance of
what Jesus commands his disciples to do next.
Matthew 28, verses 19 through 20, what does it say?
What's his command?
The great commission go, go you
therefore into all nations.
Yeah, go make disciples of all nations.
So do you see it there?
What's that command ultimately
say, oh, and be fruitful.
Yeah, be fruitful and multiply. It's the same command.
Yes, maybe it looks a little different than
procreating in the sense of making more humans,
but he is saying make more image bearers, more people
that look like Jesus, that follow Jesus,
that bear the name of Jesus.
It says fill the earth, fill the earth, multiply all nations
with the image of Jesus, the son of God.
So I know that's a long backstory to this
and you're probably asking art,
we saw a lot of that last week.
So what does all this have to do with the doctrine of man
as male and female?
That's supposed to be our topic tonight, right?
So what does all that backstory have to do with this?
Well, quite a lot as we're gonna see.
For one, it's rather obvious that the presence of male
and female humans is a bit of a requirement to multiply.
Um, hopefully everyone's already had the talk
that's not news to you hopefully, but that's not all.
'cause as we look at the nature of humanity as defined
by two distinct sexes, we begin to grasp
a greater understanding For what it means
to fulfill God's design,
to be his image bearers, filling the earth.
So by examining this collective unity
of mankind is both male and female.
And the design pattern of humans being unified then
dispersed or multiplied
and then unified again under God's design.
We see how God has made this identity
of being made in his image
to be a not individual one, but a collective
One For
humanity as a collective species
to reflect God throughout the earth.
It takes variation in our unity and in our variations.
We're gonna see that tonight specifically as God has done
that through creating man as male and female.
So in the book that you're studying
through our bible doctrine book, Grham states that
although the creation of man is male
and female is not the only way
in which we we're in the image of God,
it is a significant enough aspect of our creation
in the image of God that scripture mentions it in the very
same verse in which it describes God's
initial creation of man.
It goes on to say that the creation of man is male
and female shows God's image
in one harmonious interpersonal relationships,
two in the equality in personhood and importance,
and three in our differences in role and authority.
So we're gonna look at each of those in a little bit more
detail tonight.
So we're gonna start first with the first of those points.
Point number one is in our personal relationships.
So thinking back to Genesis,
what's the first thing in scripture
that is stated to not be good,
Be alone?
Yeah, he says that man should be alone.
That that is not good.
The first thing that we see, do you know
what the Hebrew word for alone is?
Any idea?
It's Bad literally b,
a d bad.
And I find that so interesting that the one thing
that God says is not good is human loneliness.
It's the first thing to be described in our English word is
also a Hebrew that's bad.
But we know that God doesn't create bad things, does he?
Right? So we find out as we continue to read the story
that is designed for humanity includes the remedy
for this condition of aloneness.
Gruden says that God did not create human beings
to be isolated persons,
but in making us in his image, he made us in such a way
that we can attain interpersonal unity
of various sorts in all forms of human society.
This unity of humanity is especially deep in the family,
both in our inner, both in our relational families
and then ultimately in our spiritual family
and the church between men and women.
This interpersonal unity is experienced in a unique
and profound way in marriage where scripture states
that two individual persons are united as one flesh.
We see that in Genesis two verse 24.
So to get a clearer picture of how this design works,
we're gonna spend a little bit of time in
that particular passage.
So I want us to look here at the creation
of Eve in Genesis two.
So turn with me to Genesis two
and we're gonna look at verses 19 through 25.
I'll read that for us.
It says, now out of the ground the Lord God had formed every
beast of the field and every bird of the heavens
and brought them to the man to see what he would call them.
And whatever the man called every living creature
that was its name, the man gave names
to all livestock and to the birds of the heavens
and to every beast of the field.
But for Adam, there was not found a helper fit for.
So the Lord God caused a deep sleep to fall upon the man.
And while he slept, he took one of his ribs
and closed up its place with flesh
and the rib that the Lord God had taken from the man he made
into a woman and brought her to the man.
Then the man said this, this at last is bone of my bones,
in flesh of my flesh.
She shall be called a woman
because she was taken out of man.
And the narrator gives narrator of this story,
gives a little bit of like context.
It says, Hey listen, pay attention to this.
Therefore man shall leave his father and mother
and hold fast to his wife and they shall become one flesh.
And the man and his wife are both naked
and we're not ashamed.
So I want us to take a few note of a few things here.
One, God has a purpose
and intentionality in everything that he does.
So in this story, he caught on to what's kind of happening.
It appears that God initially created a male
and female version of every living creature except for man.
And then God proceeded to parade these couples
of creatures in front of the man so that he can name them.
And so Adam, you're just picturing him sitting there
is seeing, you know, a couple of elephants come by, each
of their counterparts have, that's an elephant too.
You know, he sees a lion
and a lioness come by and sees them.
He sees a couple green ones, I dunno however this looks.
But each, each of those he's seeing,
they all have their counterpart, but I don't have mine.
And so God letting Adam see this then puts him into sleep
and makes Eve right.
It's almost as if God is intentionally delaying his creating
work here in order to draw the man's attention
and ours as the reader to this intrinsic desire
and need for interpersonal relationship
that we have as humans.
So scripture says there was not found a helper fit for him.
I think we kind of miss a little bit of what is meant by
that term, uh, with our English transition of, of helper.
So the Hebrew word that's we translate
as helper often in our English translation translations
is a,
and it's used 22 times in the Old Testament,
twice in this passage,
but the other 20 times throughout the Old Testament,
the word is not used to convey helper as
as like an assistant
or uh, someone who acts on behalf of the word.
Azer is actually used every other single time to speak
of some help in the sense of deliverance
or a as in a battle situation.
Some examples of this are Psalm one 15, verse nine,
Oh Israel trust in the Lord.
He is their help and their shield.
Psalm 1 21 verse one, it's used there.
The psalm says, I lift my eyes to the hills from
where does my help?
Azer come from my help.
Azer comes from the Lord who made heaven and earth.
So when you start to understand the word azer, not as help
as an assistant,
but as someone who comes to the aid of the delivering aid of
it starts to carry a little bit of different weight, right,
than just someone who merely assists.
This is especially highlighted when we pair it
with the Hebrew word for the phrase fit for him.
So this is the word ne
and then the context iso.
So azer connector, which carries the meaning of in front of
or opposite of corresponding to
or parallel to.
So put those translations together
and ultimately what God is saying is, I will make a help
corresponding to the man.
So when we hear the word helper, we shouldn't think
of a sidekick or an assistant,
but really of a strong ally.
Someone essential to God's purpose of reflecting his image.
So God causes the man to fall in a deep sleep
and he takes when already who has translations, say a rib.
But the Hebrew word is, which is really a,
an architectural term,
which is every other time it's translated, is translated
like the side of a building.
So he takes this side from the man
and from that side he forms the woman.
So we have this picture of what's happening is that you had
one man that God splits
and he forms two
Assault And forms two outta that.
And then the man upon seeing the the help corresponding
to him that God has made says, ah, finally,
bone of my bones, flesh of my flesh, she shall be called
woman, which is the word is Isha
because she was taken out of man each.
So there's a word play even showing that this is
too many out of the one.
So you're starting to see the beauty of
how God created mankind to reflect his image.
We're starting to see a little bit of a picture that there's
some multiple multiplication here, but still yet one.
So coming back to our first verse,
God created man in his image.
This word man is a do
capitalize that a do which is humanity.
Mankind later becomes a proper name for Adam.
But in here in this sense is Adam.
So God created mankind in his image, In the image
of God, he created him a singular masculine,
and then male and female,
he created them plural at that point.
So we start to see this progressive picture of
how God has created mankind.
One, he created all of mankind as a collective
to reflect his image.
He created him a singular in his image,
but then progressively he creates both two from one
to be his image.
So from one being created in the image of God,
God created two distinct persons, male
and female, who now equally bear his image
both being equally fully human, yet different
and corresponding to each other for mutual benefit
and for corporate reflection.
Still either without the other, could not represent
what it means to be human on our own.
The male on his own could not represent what it means
to be fully human, just as in the female
could not fully represent what it means to be human
and to reflect the image of God.
But together they do.
So this makeup that we start to see played out here
can be seen to reflect in some degree the plurality
of persons that we see within the Trinity.
It's not a perfect picture of that
because these two are distinct persons
that operate outside of each other.
God is not that way in the Trinity.
They're all equally at the same time God at the same time.
But we're getting a picture of what that looks like.
But one thing that this does reflect in God is absolutely,
it reflects our relational makeup in the same way
that God is relational, the Trinity is relational.
So that brings us to point number two.
The image of God, male and female reflects God
and our equality and personhood and importance.
So just as members of Trinity are equal in their importance
and in their full existence as distinct persons.
So men and women have been created by God
to be equal in their importance and personhood.
So both men and women are, are made equally in God's image.
Both men and women reflect God's character in their
existence, in their makeup.
In the female. We see certain aspects of God
that we don't see in the male
and in the male we see certain aspects of God
that we don't see in the female
and in relationships between males and females
and every combination of the two in the relationships
of males, of males, females, females,
all sorts of relationships.
Not just talking about marriage
or sexual relationships,
just talking about humanity relationships.
Together we see certain aspects of God
that are only possible
by this unified diversity of mankind.
So there's a, there's a side note here that I wanna make.
That this idea extends even further into the diversity
that we see in various human cultures.
Ethnic, I can't say that word, and this these tribes
and nations, there are aspects of God's image in all
of these that we wouldn't see if we just narrowed our scope
to one people group.
If our scope of humanity was just Edmond, Oklahoma America,
there are aspects of God's image reflected in humanity
that we would never see.
But when you compare that with people groups in Africa,
in Asia, and a lot in Oklahoma,
trust me, that's a people group in itself.
You see a bigger picture
of mankind reflecting God's image in
all sorts of different ways.
Groom says that if we live in a society consisting
of only Christian men
or society consisting of only Christian women,
we would not gain as full a picture of the character of God
as when we see both godly men and godly women
and their complimentary differences
together reflecting the beauty of God's character,
the equality of men
and women is further emphasized in the new Covenant church.
We see this at Pentecost when a prophecy from
Joel is, Luke writes,
I'll pour out my spirit upon all flesh.
And your sons and your daughters,
both male female shall prophesy and on my man's servants
and my maid servants, in those days, I'll pour out my spirit
and may shall prophesy.
See, the Holy Spirit is poured out
in power on both men
and both women believers and in the church.
This diversification of humanity
that is bound together by holy unity.
It continues to shine even beyond the male
and female dichotomy.
Paul says in Galatians, he says, for as many
of you were baptized into Christ, have put on Christ,
there is neither Jew nor Greek.
There is neither slave nor free.
There's neither male
nor female for you are all one in Christ Jesus.
You collectively are all one in Christ Jesus.
It's not to say that we are all homogenous
as if we all looked and acted
and were the exact same exactly like in every way.
But on the contrary, God equips
and gifts the church in a multitude
of different ways from different backgrounds,
different cultures to build up, to care for
and to bear the image of Jesus collectively.
He also says in one Corinthians 12, 18 and 19, he says,
but as it is, God arranged the members of in the body,
each one of them as he chose.
If all were a single member, where would the body be
as it is, there are many parts, yet one body.
So this leads us to our third point, that while equally
that while we share equality
and value status importance among all humans,
including between males
and females, God has designed different roles
to be carried out by men
and women within the context of the family
and within the church.
So here we are to differences in roles.
How does this play out in practicality?
So one area we see this biblically is roles in the family.
So for the sake of time, I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on the roles here,
but I do want to note a few distinct roles here
that God has purpose for many time.
And I do wanna point out that these roles are purpose both
before and after the fall.
These are from original designs, aren't things
that are a reaction to the fall that he then said, well
because of sin, we're gonna put these roles in place.
These were roles designed from the kingdom.
So in marriage relationships we see that God has purposed
for the husband to have a authority over the wife,
though they remain equal in person, we see that the wife is
to live in submission under the headship of the husband.
And we see that the husband is to love
and care for his wife
in a sacrificial servant leader way.
And we see that a marriage that exists in this way results
in a complimentary, flourishing union where the one flesh
made up of the husband and the wife loves honors
and respects one another, working together
for the ultimate glory, reflecting our savior Jesus Christ
and his relationship to the church.
That's what ultimately the whole purpose
of marriage is there to do,
is reflect Jesus' perfect union
with his body, with his bride.
So I know the words,
there might be a little bit triggering authority
or submission, and let's talk about that.
So the words authority
and submission tend to get a bad rap in today's culture.
Why do you think that is? Why do people
object to the words authority
or submission, especially in context of
the marriage relationship?
I think it makes it seem like one's nice
or one more above the mm-hmm.
Any other thoughts?
I say we kind of have a problem with that word, regardless
of you're a man or a woman.
I think we have a problem with that word in general today.
Yeah. Nobody likes it.
Yeah. To have an Authority over
Them, not just in the marriage relationship,
but just authority in general kind of makes you cringe.
That bar's already kind of set lower,
I think. Yeah,
yeah, exactly.
And, and rightfully, rightfully so.
It has a bad wrap in our culture sometimes
because as we all know, those roles, the application
of those roles have been abused
and distorted in such a way
that they leave this bad taste in our lives
because we've experienced it being distorted abuse,
being distorted out of authority,
submission being taken advantage of.
But here I'm gonna remind you that Jesus, the son of God,
an equal person of the Trinity Scripture tells us,
submitted himself to the father's will.
And this was a good thing both for his glory
and for our good as we see scripture played out.
And if you struggle with the idea
of a husband's God ordained authority in the marriage,
take a look at Matthew 20, verse 25 to 28,
and consider how Jesus, the exact image of God
chooses to rule in authority.
This is what Jesus says.
He says, when Jesus called them to him
and said, you know that the rulers
of the Gentiles lorded over them
and their great ones exercise authority over them,
talking about this abusive, um, way that authorities use,
he says, it shall not be so among you,
but whoever would be great among you must be your servant
and whoever would be first among you must be your slave.
Even as the son of man came not to be served, but to serve.
And he gave his life as a ransom for many.
So in Jesus's words, to rule as image bearers like Jesus,
to have authority as image bearers,
what does Jesus instruct us to do?
What does he instruct the husband to do?
How should he exercise authority?
Be a servant? To be a servant, yeah.
To give of himself just as Jesus did for the church.
And so when you think about that relationship, us
as husbands that challenge us, step into
that leadership role in the marriage,
step into that authority role.
But as a servant, servant hearted, how do I serve my wife,
how I love her sacrificially.
Um, Joe Williams, and I'm going off a little tangent here.
Joe Williams, uh,
pointed out a great example of this to me one time.
He said, authority, oftentimes in our society, we think
of as a pyramid, right?
Where the person at the top is the one authority
and all those in submission are serving
and holding up the one authority,
but it's not so in God's kingdom really,
authority is more like a tree
where the person in authority is more like the roots
down here pulling up nutrients, pulling up things
to support the whole structure so that the one
that is submitting is the one
that's out here basically shining.
And the authority structure is really the ones serving
the rest of the union.
So I would encourage us to think then of
how do we do this for our wives?
How do we support and lead and,
and nurture our wives in that way?
But going on past the marriage relationship
and parental relationships to sons
and daughters, we see that fathers
and mothers biblically are called to operate
and shared authority over the children, serving them
and leading them out of love
and strength, not stirring them up to anger,
but spurring the children on to wisdom and godliness.
And we see that both parents, the mother
and the father, are worthy of honor
and obedience in child to parent relationships.
Sons and daughters are to honor their parents
and obey them equally.
And then in sibling relationships, brothers
and sisters are to love one another
and bury each other's burdens.
So these roles, while not perfectly parallel, they do,
um, carry some semblance over to
how they're applied in the church
and they're similar, yet different roles prescribed
for the family of God in the church.
For sake of time, we're not gonna
be able to do all this tonight.
But, uh, if you want to gain a more thorough understanding
of these roles, I'm gonna point you
to our roles in ministry paper that's over here printed out.
Um, the elders finalized
and distributed this earlier this year,
and so I would encourage you to take that
and view that to get a more thorough understanding of
how we view biblical roles applied in the church
for both males and females and how we serve together.
But I will just address one key question here tonight as it,
uh, pertains to roles in the church
before I turn it over to Jacob
to lead us out in the discussions.
And that one question that most have when it comes
to church is this, should some governing
and teaching roles in the church be reserved for men?
There's basically two primary views within,
uh, Christianity about how this question should be answered.
On the one hand, you have egalitarians
and they emphasize equality between men and women.
They hold that, I'm talking in generalities here,
but primarily, generally they hold that no governing
or teaching roles in the church are reserved for men.
That all positions are open to both men and women alike.
And there are some scriptural
emphasises emphasis that they make.
Um, I've listed those there in your notes, uni go
and review primarily
what their scriptural emphasis, emphasis is.
On the other hand, you have complimentarians, they emphasize
that men and women, while equal
and value, have complimentary differences.
And they hold that some governing
and teaching roles in church are reserved just for men,
although exactly which roles would vary according
to the nomination and the congregation.
And I've listed there the scriptural emphasis
for complementarians with the main passages that they go to.
There's, there's more of the needs, um, on both sides,
but these are the primary ones.
The last thing I'll say on this is that the HHBC,
the Henderson Hills Elder position,
and I would refer you again to the roles
and ministry for more explanation.
But in short, we see in scripture
that God has reserved the offices of elder
or overseer, uh,
and the office of Deacon, uh, to be for men in the church.
But we strongly encourage the participation of both men
and women to appropriately use, appropriately,
use their giftings as God equips to build up the body
and glorify Jesus in his kingdom.
And if you have any questions on any of those things, I know
that was quickly run through, please
ask me, ask for the elders.
We had to have more of that conversation with you
as we spent a lot of time studying that topic together.
Alright, I'm gonna end there.
I'm gonna turn it over to Jacob, who is going to lead us,
uh, in a little bit more discussion on this topic.
Good
Evening. Also, I'm
just gonna lead a, uh, kind
of a short discussion time based off of what Chris said.
Um, and so I'm just going to kind
of list off maybe a few like things, you know,
brain thinking about some of this stuff.
And then we'll kind of talk about some application questions
in our lives, ways we can apply.
But really just want to highlight unity,
diversity kind Trinity and how that applies to us.
How forward we see unity within us as people.
Um, so just gonna, uh, read a few things
that was in, in the book.
Uh, so, so it says
that God did not create humans to be isolated.
Medicine is image, which means having interpersonal unity.
We see that interpersonal unity, uh, within the trinity
and created us spread also.
So this unity can be especially deep in our human family,
but also in our erritory
spiritual family here in the church.
And so kind of some questions that I want to throw out just
for us to discuss as a group.
You know, first off, thinking about this
idea of interpersonal unity.
So how have you personally experienced
God's image reflected in others
through relationships in your life?
So for the purpose of discussion, we're gonna exclude,
we're gonna exclude marriage because
that would be an easy one.
So let's just think about the church,
your relationships in your life.
How have you experienced God's image reflected
in those relationships?
Loyalty, experience, loyalty
and relationships of
God's loyalty.
What else?
I'd Say serving one another.
Serving teaching.
Can you expand on that one just a little bit?
Um, I'm taught by so many people every day,
including my wife,
Other people, often so many things about get a group
of people together, people often bring other insights
that maybe I'm a very black and white thinker.
So people can bring insights to that.
How about loving and caring? Loving and caring.
Corporate worship is encouraging.
So on the flip side of that, so that was
how we see God's image reflected.
Okay. And others. So flipping around the opposite,
thinking about isolation.
So how does living in isolation impact our ability
to reflect God's image?
See it?
What else? Living in isolation.
How does it impact our relationships? Like
Jake? I have a
question. Yeah.
Do you Mean, uh, isolation in, in general or isolation?
Female, male and female.
You mean isolation, just in general. Isolation.
No one's pouring into you
and you're not pouring into anyone else.
So you're not really having a time dedicated to
learning from other people the image of God.
And they're not, you're not allowing yourself
to show you image you
Previously stated.
I I think you see it manifest throughout our society
today, lover of oneself, one upmanship,
self-centeredness, not caring
for others, all those things.
You can't reflect that if you're,
if you're concentrating only on yourself and your own needs.
Yeah,
Yeah. Mike Chris talked
about we see the image
of God in people all throughout the world.
So we don't get to see that just in isolation to see, uh,
other ways, uh, that God has reflected in other people.
So next kind of just, uh, ing point.
So as members of the Trinity are equal in their importance
and in their existence as distinct persons.
So men and women have also been created by God
to be equal in their importance and their personhood.
So when God created them, he created them male
and female in his image, as we talked about.
So men and women are made equally in God's image.
Both men and women reflect God's character in their lives.
This means that we should see aspects
of God's character reflected in each other's lives.
Um, and Chris mentioned this so
that if we live in a society consisting
of only Christian men
or of only Christian women, we would not gain a full picture
of character of God.
'cause when we see both godly men
and godly women in their complimentary differences
reflecting the beauty of God's character.
So thinking along those lines, how do men
and women each reflect something unique
about God's character?
So I, I think, uh, in Genesis,
so when God created a woman, so God said the word, uh,
I will create a helper for you, but uh,
before Jesus died, he decide I will be with uh God Father,
but I will send the helper,
which is a Holy Spirit, a Holy Spirit.
And, uh, Jesus there evil and man, a woman there.
How do men and women reflect
Something unique about God's character?
The nails got anything. Nurturing.
Nurturing.
Did you say one more than The other?
You know, uh, I'm reminded of a story I heard a missionary
share years ago.
It was pre nine 11.
He was a missionary in Afghanistan before nine 11.
And he talked about, um, you know,
all the women were covered and all the women were hidden.
And it was just this sort of coal hard male world.
And not just maleness in its glory and image of God,
but sort of a, this sort of sad, repressed hard,
you know, world and leap
and, uh, some things that have been excel at, right?
Like, uh, it's, it's one of the reasons men are valuable
and important is
because they can, they're called women can do it too,
but men uniquely can go out and, you know, plumb buildings
and fight battles and you know what I mean?
All those things, sort of the physicality of it.
But I remember him talking about the image
of God in particular, not on display in the sense
that it was solely the maleness of that world
and there was no feminine sort of, uh, side of all that.
And I just, that was the first time I kind
of seen that in my mind.
I thought that was interesting
Because You, you lose a lot either way, right?
Like I think even our culture, we sort of
have a recent history of trying to eradicate maleness in,
in some ways we wanna diminish that.
Now, obviously we wanted to diminish male simpleness,
but there's also, there's male righteousness
and female righteousness, female sinfulness,
female righteousness.
And we want to elevate the righteous parts,
our god of both things.
Okay, next, just thinking about, uh,
authority and submission.
God, the Father has always been,
the Father is always related to the Son as a father.
It relates to the Son. And though all three members
of the Trinity are equal in power
and in all attributes, the Father does
have greater authority.
He has a leadership role among the members of the Trinity
that the Son and the Holy Spirit do not have.
And each member of the Trinity has
these distinct roles and functions.
And so thinking along those lines, what, what can we learn?
Because we, we talked about
how this like submission has its negative
view in our society.
What can we learn from Jesus's submission
to the father's authority?
It is a choice because Jesus, if he really wanted to,
he could have done other things at that moment.
And he chose the problem, the Father.
And it's a beautiful thing too, that submission
that we see in, in Jesus to the Father.
It's not authoritarian, it's not that,
like you said, it's, it's a choice.
It was willing, he willingly submitted to the Father
because he knows ultimately who the Father is.
And it's, it's just supposed to be that way
and it's beautiful that way.
And we, we, we warped that
right in our definitions of authority or how we view
or have seen authority play out in some ways in this world,
but done properly as it's modeled by Jesus is a
Beautiful thing, A good point about,
we were discussing earlier that it's viewed badly
and it's almost like submission is enforcing.
I think we confuse the idea of authority and power.
Power
And also, uh, his submission,
he has a relationship with the Father.
He spend time on plea to the Father
and he knows, uh, father's work, you know, in Bible also
of ways talking about the fighting, you know, fighting Jesus
and hide my work.
So when Bible come to, uh, Jesus,
he can directly code, uh, from the Bible.
So he has a relationship with the Father.
I think too, there's, uh, equality on display
right there equally the,
with sort of various roles,
Quality of submission.
But the quality is the, the, uh,
equality is not a question.
Yeah.
Yes.
I think that we as Americans have a special problem
With authority because
We got rid of kings
and we ourselves don't trust our government.
So we have three separate branches
of government competing against one another.
So none of them have authority over us.
And then we've got our guns so that if they do,
you know, we are an authority.
If we don't like our boss, we leave.
We're probably the least authoritarian nation in the world.
But one thing about Jesus
and his love of the authority over him
is there's a love and intimacy.
He just adored the Father.
Maybe my favorite thing just from this chapter
that was in the book, it says that, uh,
as we grow in maturity in Christ, we'll grow to delight in
and rejoice in the God ordained
and wisely created differences in
roles within the human family.
When we understand this biblical teaching, what men
and women should be able to say in their hearts, this is
what God has planned and it is beautiful and right.
And I rejoice in the way he has made me in a distinct
role he has given me.
There is eternal beauty and dignity
and rightness in this differentiation in roles both within
the trinity and within the human family.
It does sense of better or worse, a sense of more important
or less important, but men, both men
and women, should be able to rejoice fully
in the way that they have been made.
So the last just discussion question for y'all.
So how does the unity
and diversity in the Trinity serve as a model
for human relationships
and diversity in the Trinity?
How does serve as a model for human relationships?
Different Roles,
Different Roles?
So diversity,
I'd say the cool thing about it is that it works.
I think one of the really beautiful things about it's
that there's a, there's a mutual respect honoring
of each person and our relationships.
When you look around this room, you meet eyes
with everyone in here and you view one another as
you distinctly carry part of the image of God
and the way that he's creating you.
When you reflect him rightly, Especially among us
as believers, we get to share
that even a more elevated sense
because we share the Holy Spirit within us.
We share this image that he's making us into Jesus.
And yet we could still look around
and see there's so much variation, so much difference.
And Brad, the things that you reflect about, uh, God
and Jesus and what he's doing in your heart
through your experiences are things that I can't replicate
seeing you, Dan, you Mark, it's, it's incredible to see
how God allows us to experience
that in our relationships together.
And as we don't live in isolation throughout, we live
and we lean into those relationships, we begin to appreciate
the, uh, bond that we share in God and history one
and Him all at the same time.
It's even kind of hard to talk about in ways
that make sense, but it's really beautiful mystery.
It's Almost like you said, it's not good.
Alright, thanks guys. Um, to, uh,
again, I just wanna remind us
what we're ultimately talking about is the image
of God, right?
We're talking about men, women, we're talk about humanity.
At the end of the day, what we primarily want
to get our hearts and our minds around, especially
as we wrap up, but I always want to go to the reason
that I always want to end with a worship song is that, uh,
we want to not just think thoughts,
but we wanna stir our emotions towards God,
stir our affections towards him.
Uh, before we do this,
I'm technologically challenged again.
Here we go. Uh,
before we do it, just two things in your packet,
I give out two other documents.
Just you may wanna read the danver statement on biblical
manhood and womanhood and the national statement,
a coalition for biblical sexuality, just, uh, pastors
and theologians try to wrestle with some
of these things in a cultural context,
in our cultural context.
And, uh, anyway, you may wanna read that as you go along.
Add that too. It's not required reading,
but I want look at that as well.
Um, The last thing that I want to say, uh,
that I was thinking about, just listening
to our conversation, does I see them off.
Um, the last thing, so it's just standing in my way just
to use that is, is this,
like whenever we think about, you know,
sometimes people say, well, it's hard for me to think about
God as a father 'cause I had a bad dad,
or it's hard for me to think about, um,
the Lord in terms of husband and wife
'cause you know, I had a bad husband, right?
Whatever. You know, you have different things like that.
And, and the goal I think in humanity is
that when we see what's good in humanity,
when we see what's good in certain individuals is you say,
well, that's about God.
That actually reflects the goodness and nature of God.
And where you see things that are not like God
and they're bad, right?
Everything God made is good, but
whenever we see things that are bad in humanity,
whether it's husbands and wives or fathers or mothers
or whatever it might be, is those things remind us literally
what God is not like.
And so we can take comfort by the fact that God's not like
that, but these are the things God is like, in fact, the,
the, the negative.
If you fill that void with what it ought to be,
and that's a at least some echo of what, what God's
more like, okay?
Doesn't always tell us all the details,
but just could to keep in mind that,
that in humanity we really do have the image of God, men
and women and also men and living together.
Just like I love the way you drew that out.
So anyway, uh, how, what's the time? I'm all 48. 48 48.
We got three minutes to sing a five minute song.
So, uh, let's do this. If you gotta go,
as they say, you gotta go.
And so, so feel free to take off if you're, if you're,
if you're able, you can stand if you want to stay seated.
Either way, I just encourage this, take a few minutes
to sing an old song, come about fout of every blessing.
It turns our hearts to that, that,
that God is the source of all that is good.
If you're not able to stay in sync with us,
then sing it on your way out the door.
And uh, thanks for coming
Every blessing to
of mercy.
Call for songs loudest.
I Was Darkness
to You came, rescued me.
I was,
It goes on. But
lemme just close this in great time.
God, we do thank you that you are the foun,
you are the fountain, the source of every blessing.
We thank you for the goodness
that you have put on display in the world that you have made
and, and uniquely
and especially in the way we've talked about it in the last
two weeks in your creation of humanity.
We thank you for your goodness to us, in
the way you have made men.
Thank you for the goodness to us,
in the way you have made women.
And Lord, we thank you for the way in which in Christ
we're being made new day by day
and one day we will be made
completely whole again.
And that all of humanity in Christ that are trusting in Him,
that are glorified at the end of the world, at the end
of this age, that we will become like you.
And that our sin
and our brokenness will not only just be paid for,
but it will be done away with.
And Lord, we look forward to that day. We long for that day.
And I pray in the meantime that in our relationships,
whether it's as husband or wife or brother and sister
or parent and child
or siblings, those inner relationships between other,
uh, human beings, but then also especially across male
and female bounds, Lord, we pray you would give us grace.
You would give us power to walk in a way
that brings you glory and honor.
And Lord we love you and we thank you for in Jesus name.
Amen. Amen. Alright, ready.